der Hitlergruß Skandal um
ballermann-star Melanie Müller sorgt für
Empörung in ganz Deutschland bei einem
Auftritt in Leipzig reißt sie den Arm
acht Mal zu der verbotenen Geste in die
Luft wie tief steckt Melanie Müller im
rechtsradikalen Sumpf bei uns spricht
jetzt ihr Ex-Mann
der nazi-klam die gefallene
Dschungelkönigin Melanie Müller Bild
Reporter Markus Langner will von Müllers
noch Ehemann Mike Blümer wissen wie er
den Videoausschnitt bewertet
hat grundsätzlich ihr Mikrofon in der
rechten Hand und macht mit Links schon
diese Andeutungen die also nicht
Andeutung Gottes
nein um die Leute mit der linken Hand zu
animieren mitzumachen sage ich jetzt mal
sie anzukurbeln um sie zum Feiern für
animieren aber in der Form habe ich noch
nicht von ihr erlebt zicke zacke zicke
zacke das ist ja das ist ihr
anfeuerungshof gar keine Frage aber die
Art und Weise wie ich das dort sehen
musste habe ich noch nicht von ihr
erlebt fakt ist im Video Reck Müller
mehrfach die rechte Hand in eindeutiger
Manier nach oben ausschreitet Müller in
einem zweiten Video nicht sofort ein als
Konzertbesuche Nazi parolenburg
Melanie Müller streitet eine Nähe zum
Rechtsradikalismus ab schreibt bei
Instagram ich habe mit rechtsradikalen
oder nationalistischen Gedankengut
nichts am Hut ich Stelle das auf
schärfste auch in einer Sprachnachricht
an Bild bestreitet die ehemalige Promi
big brotherin den Vorwurf rechtsextrem
zu sein ich bin weder Rechts organisiert
ich weiß es nicht keine Ahnung war ich
das jemals Mike Blümer teilt sich mit
seiner Ex das gemeinsame Sorgerecht für
die beiden Kinder Mia und Matti wo sind
die denn jetzt momentan
sind und noch ein paar andere
Gegebenheiten in unserer
Auseinandersetzung unsere Trennung bei
mir ich habe die Kinder gestern aus der
Kind aus der Kita geholt und die Kinder
bleiben jetzt vorsorglich erstmal bei
mir
auf keinen Fall möchte dass meine Kinder
oder unsere Kinder irgendwelche
Anfeindungen bezüglich meiner Frau
erleben müssen Melanie Müller reagiert
nicht mehr auf unsere Interviewanfragen
in ihrem letzten Instagram Statement
stellt sie die aktuelle Situation aber
so da wie geht es deshalb wirklich
schlecht und ich denke auch an meine
Kinder die schützen muss und die solche
Lügen über ihre Mutter nicht lesen
wollen das möchte ich nicht dass das
meine Kinder
in beziehungsweise in einer Frau durch
das Verstehen durch die Präsenz meiner
Frau erleben müssen deswegen konnte
behalte ich die Kinder jetzt sondern
Erklärung oder bist du irgendwann nicht
muss die Kinder schützen Melanie Müller
ruinieren diese 16 Sekunden nicht nur
ihre Karriere als trashi-krone sondern
auch ihr Privatleben
[Applaus]
[Musik]